[Applause]
and i wouldn't make jokes about it
because it's really serious and racist
okay
and like me i care a lot about this
issue okay you yeah
i'm not racist i care about racist
issues that happen in the world so
basically
basically one guy fouls the other guy
and if you play a video you can see it
you don't need to even do subtitles
flagrant one or two
wait what no okay
dude look at the ref now did he say the
n word which is an english word or did
he use
there's another word that spanish people
use the spanish version right
which is spelled n e g
r a t a yes something like that yeah and
there was a coach that said it as well i
think it was the coach this is back in
the day it was like the spanish
team coach whatever like that anyway
basically he says it the guy starts
going wild and
they start fighting each other and
they're pissed and then his whole team
walks off the field with him wow were
they winning or losing it was tie game
tie game 30 minutes so like
in the first half game left a lot of
match left
wow okay
is this an appropriate response you just
walk out the field quit the game if
someone says it yep
you try to reconcile you try to come
back on the field how do you play i mean
if the guy is gonna say that
and like you have a recorder and it's
proof the i mean immediately
gets kicked out the game not even
question um
unless he's black and then say it as
much as you want
but uh but uh but yeah you immediately
kick him out of the game
i think you but yeah you just kicked
that person out of the game i guess that
could be like the same like a red card
or something i don't know what it would
be used i think in
in basketball they'd probably just give
you an immediate ejection
yeah yeah yeah and then you'd be
suspended for quite some time
yeah 100 so uh but his team
the black guy who got called the n-word
his team decided that they were just
going to walk off they were going to
leave they were going to boycott
uh which is dope because it's solidarity
yeah yeah i like it
that's your teammates going yo listen we
obviously don't see you like that
[ __ ] that person and we got your back
what i don't
want what i don't know how what to do
here is like how do you set the
precedent
right like if they end up losing this
game if they end up forfeiting this game
what happens when you're in the
championship if you're in a championship
and you're down three goals someone's
dropping the airport
so you don't want to set a precedent
where you can win a game by just saying
the n-word you don't want to reward the
races
i think you got to call it a tie right
don't that could be a reward for them
too you're down three goals you n-word
it up and now you're
okay the tie game so i'm just saying you
based it on in this case it's 1-1 so
that's
the game ends like that if you're down
three goals and it ends you're down
three goals right
right it's usually a problem with the
fans in european soccer and it's such a
huge problem i've seen them walk off
their races because they need to do
something yeah but they need to do
something
that hard and fast to set the president
like you need to police your own like
it's usually the ultras and the you know
the folks in the end zone that like
are the die hards you got to get they
want to do it now quick walk off the
field
ruin it for everybody so it's rare to
see from actually on the field too
yeah yeah i like that yo does that ever
happen in f1
formula one yeah do are they saying the
n word no
are the f crowd saying racist stuff
towards um
i mean the guy's going 150 miles per
hour i think you can hear an end
he gets he gets historically a lot of
time you see him coming around all right
everybody on your market set go and then
hopefully he hears it on the way he's
wearing a helmet he's got
things plugged in there's no way they
can hear it and the car engine
doesn't happen what do they sound like
does it sound like it you're referring
to lewis hamilton and he's spoken that
it's
it's not just a fans he thinks that the
in the organization
since he started winning from karting
and on up and was always like
the one black guy that he would see he's
always felt that they've created a new
rule like
a new lewis hamilton rule because of him
to find ways to kind of like
keep him cornered he's always felt that
he's been keeping quarters he's won
seven in a row no no but
coming up in formula one there's it
always seems like he is he says
that he feels like he's maybe it made
him drive targeted being targeted by
what if you're the guy in the lead yeah
you're being targeted
people want to beat you i'm not just
talking about no i'm talking about
coming up in the sport and formula one
you're not looking at him you're looking
at mercedes mercedes mercedes
yeah i'm sorry what are we supposed to
believe with with lewis hamilton like
we're supposed to believe that like he
hasn't been giving the mo
best opportunity he's literally been the
number one driver
on the number one team for the last
seven years he's won seven championships
it's like yeah i i have a hard time
accepting that like
f1 has been holding him back if anything
they've been propping him
up furthermore there's an argument to be
made that his teammate
isn't really that good and he's there to
lose to lewis
uh botos what is his name valtteri
bottas right
furthermore he's sick with kovid one
race last year
this guy russell what is his name jordan
george russell who is on this bum team
williams is like the worst team that's
always out there right
he goes and takes his position for that
one race
leads the whole [ __ ] race and then he
goes in for a final
final a final pit stop oops
we gave you the wrong tires
oops come back in the tires are still
working
come back in we mix up your tires you
think a
german racing team is going to make a
little oopsy daisy
or do you think they were trying to
protect lewis hamilton's reputation
as the best driver ever when some random
guy who literally is coming last
every single race gets into the best car
and is all of a sudden the number one
i think they've been protecting lewis
hamilton i think they love the fact that
he is
one an amazing driver don't get me wrong
the guy's an amazing driver but he's
also in the best car
and it's the constructors championship
it's not the drivers championship it's
who makes the best car and you can
almost put any idiot in the car and
they're going to end up winning right
and i think they love the fact that they
have the most unique driver on the
on the field or whatever you call it on
the wait wait the racetrack offers like
hard to have heaviest
which is like it's very clear he wasn't
a rich
it's like you're competing against like
the former drivers themselves and their
sons
coming up in the sport versus like
lewis's dad who's not in the sport is
buying his son a go-kart and
yeah upbringing as many of these other
named it's like a rich kid sport right
yeah it is a rich kid sport 100 percent
of rich kid sport like there's a guy
named um
stroll right lance whose father is
lawrence
lauren stroll right and he's a
billionaire and he owns the [ __ ] team
and it's amazing for anyone go watch
drive to survive on netflix's
unbelievable series
it was the most fun you'll have watching
netflix i swear to god in the last when
did our show come out
start from season one but yeah there's
three seasons it's unbelievable it's so
great it's a reality show built around
it
you don't even care who wins they do an
amazing job but i don't buy this thing
that lewis hamilton has been like in
some ways suppressed
i think it's an amazing story the one
black guy in f1 happens to be the most
dominant driver in the history of the
sport
and he's on the best team and i think
they do things to protect that
reputation i think they go above and
beyond to protect that reputation
they are they could have whatever driver
they want there's another driver max
verstappen
right who some might say is better than
lewis
someone says not but he's in a worse car
if max verstappen was in the same car's
lewis
who ends up winning maybe maybe
they're not making moves for max
verstappen right they're keeping this
other guy valtteri botos that they know
is worst driver from analytics they know
he's a worse driver than lewis because
they're protecting because that's the
golden goose
we love [ __ ] who keep winning
championships yeah that [ __ ] is
the jordan
of the sport and he's more he's
marketable he's so he's a handsome as
[ __ ] guy
swag swacked out you know what i mean
might
he's too pretty bro he's too pretty
[ __ ] pretty
[Laughter]
that's a good ass point actually all i'm
trying to say is like i think that they
are protecting their golden gooses but
maybe for the sport maybe he faced
racism coming up though
undeniable that's what dove is saying
every person of color
faces racism that was the one thing no i
know
can i just clarify i'm sorry if i if you
interpret it like that i didn't think
you were talking about i know you later
said carding but i thought you meant
you said coming up in f1 i thought we
were talking about his career in f1 oh
sorry
if if i slip with that f1
just coming up and driving and karting
he definitely did not come from wealth
and he has a very really interesting
backstory his backstory is amazing it's
like
you couldn't cook up it's a [ __ ]
pixar character yeah you couldn't cook
up a better backstory it's so great
um and he's undeniably excellent
but this sport is not even playing field
like
if you have the best car you win that's
it
like you could win if you're in the best
car yeah oh my god
you really think so left turn goes like
that right turn goes like that oh my god
oh my god you're the one one of the
worst drivers i've ever met my life in
regular car
okay so if you were in a way faster more
powerful absolutely
yeah absolutely